the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over and
we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones and A
Song of Ice and Fire update video in
this new video I want to have another
discussion about the Winds of Winter the
novel everyone has been waiting for from
George RR Martin's A Song of Ice and
Fire Saga as I'm sure most of you
already know Game of Thrones and A Song
of Ice and Fire fans have been waiting
for the Winds of Winter for well over a
decade unfortunately as of right now
George RR Martin has missed every single
deadline as you all know the Winds of
Winter gets delayed every single year
well earlier this week George RR Martin
has given us another big update about
the status of the Winds of Winter and I
would argue that this may be the worst
update he's ever given now before I
discuss the new information I have to
let all of you know about this
incredibly fun game
today's video is sponsored by bloodline
Heroes of lethas this game has one of
the most unique game mechanics I've ever
seen and their Graphics always amaze me
build your kingdom and collect Champions
to defend it by creating your own unique
Legendary Champions you can combine the
Bloodlines of elves demons demigods
dwarves Dragonborn vampires and more
download and try out the game now for
free and receive an amazing starter pack
now is the best time to try out
bloodline because the game is going to
have its best update ever the new Lycan
Clan galtong is coming to the game this
Christmas with a Sleek new design with
different weapons and skill sets they
will wreak havoc combine this brand new
Bloodline with existing Bloodlines to
get even stronger hybrids for a limited
time only players will be able to obtain
a galtong champion for free by
participating in the Christmas event
starting December 22nd starting this
December battling the new guild war on
brand new maps and be rewarded with
legendary hybrids conquer territories
with your their Guild members and claim
rewards to create the most unique hybrid
Champions called bloodcraft Legends for
the first season everyone has the chance
to claim the bloodcraft champion
Scarlett a rare combination of demigods
and vampires new Bloodlines and
legendary hybrids are constantly being
released into the game so the
possibilities are endless use my link or
the QR code you see on the screen to
download bloodline for free on both
Android and iOS devices you'll also get
a special starter pack that's worth
twenty dollars that includes three
stamina potions 100 000 gold and 100
diamonds and a new Lycan Champion for
free this Christmas don't hesitate this
starter pack is only available for the
next 30 days once again I have to thank
bloodline for sponsoring today's video
now dating all the way back to the year
of 1993 George R Martin began writing a
Game of Thrones the first installment in
his A Song of Ice and Fire Fantasy Saga
over the decades it has led to the
release of many more novels as well as
several incredibly successful television
shows as of right now the Winds of
Winter is still arguably the most highly
anticipated novel ever written not only
because the fans have been waiting for
it for what seems like forever but also
because it will start to reveal how this
amazing story will end it will even help
to erase some of the memory of what
happened during the final season of Game
of Thrones what we saw happen at the end
of Game of Thrones was more or less Dan
and day's version of the events now they
did get some information from George R
Martin but they left out a significant
amount over the years while also adding
a lot of their own The Winds of Winter
and a dream of spring will be the real
ending to A Song of Ice and Fire
unfolding developing and finally
concluding in a way that the author
always intended although Game of Thrones
fumbled the ball at the goal line and
George R Martin continues to miss his
deadlines the demand and interest for
the Winds of Winter is still insanely
High regardless of when he actually
finishes it you can almost guarantee it
will immediately become a bestseller on
the same day of releases that's how much
fans still want to rate it even after
we've been let down so many times over
the years well it was only a few months
ago when George R Martin revealed he was
about three-fourths of the way done
although we all want to hear him say
he's all the way done I still thought
this was very exciting because he
normally never gives us an update with
this much Insight on most days whenever
he would give us an update on the wins
of winter he might say what character
he's working on or how many chapters he
just wrote as far as I know that was the
first time he ever revealed exactly how
much he had done or how far he still had
to go it was genuinely starting to feel
like we might see the Winds of Winter
very soon well unfortunately we will not
see it this year and it doesn't look
like we will see it during the fall
following year either in George RR
Martin's most recent update he revealed
he still had roughly 500 more pages to
write until the wins of winter is done
now I don't know about all of you but
that was a devastating Revelation this
makes me believe we will not see it for
several more years think about it if
it's already taken him over a decade to
write three-fourths of it then that most
likely means it might be another three
years before he finishes that last one
fourth when George R Martin was giving
himself deadlines he would always say it
will be another year he almost always
said one more year in fact one of the
last instances when he gave himself a
deadline he said if it wasn't released
by the summer of 2020 then he would
allow us to lock him up inside of a cell
well this upcoming summer will make
three years since he should have met
that deadline and now with the most
recent update he's no longer saying he
needs another year it now sounds like he
will need even three more years until it
gets done now unless he suddenly starts
writing out lightning speed which he has
never done I don't think we will be
getting the ones of winter anytime soon
this is why I feel like it's the worst
update he's ever given but maybe that's
only me let me know what all of you
think down below how do you feel about
this new information am I Justified for
feeling this negative or should I relax
a little bit most of you should already
know how I feel about these updates some
of them will make me feel like it's the
best news ever While others make me feel
like the ending is nowhere in sight I
need your help so I can back away from
the ledge so let me know what you think
as always I want to thank all of you for
watching another video I hope all of you
have a great day and I also want to wish
all of you a happy holidays I will see
all of you again very soon in the next
one bye
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign